it's the most prominent symbol of the
protests demonstrators have been wearing
facemasks
since the beginning of the pro-democracy
movement in Hong Kong to avoid
punishment by the government masks like
this are commonly available at
pharmacies they're a rare defense
against the widespread use of facial
recognition software by the Chinese
government
and that's a nuisance for the
authorities the problem is the
identification of the suspects who
committed many offences such as criminal
damages rious unlawful assembly wounding
of people so and many of them would be
able to avoid detection because of the
very that midnight local time on Friday
a ban on facial masks took effect in
Hong Kong along with other emergency
regulations we believe that the new law
will create a deterrent effect against
master violent protesters and riotous
and we assist the police in his law
enforcement protesters so far seem
undeterred by the new ban
[Laughter]
today you eat the government use the
power to stop us from very mas tomorrow
they can use such powers to arrange of
things
arrange things that deprive us of our
the anger among protesters has if
anything only mounted the weekend is
likely to see new clashes and more
violence DW is Charlotte chosen Pihl is
monitoring the situation in Hong Kong
and joins us now for the latest so
Charlotte
despite this new emergency law we've
seen more protests today in Hong Kong
what's been the atmosphere like after
last night's excessive violence mariana
there's a lot of trepidation here on the
streets at the moment where I'm standing
right now shops here boarding up their
windows any shops who are believed to
have pro-beijing sentiment or anti
protester sentiment are owned by
mainland China are at risk of being
targeted by protesters that is something
that we saw last nights we witnessed a
number of shops including china mobile
being vandalized we saw mobile phones
thrown to the floor screen scrapper
smashed there is a lot of concern among
people here that we're talking to about
how the night indeed how the rest of the
weekend will unfold that's because of
the sheer anger on the streets here of
Hong Kong in reaction to that protest to
that facemask ban we've seen a couple of
protests so far today there was a march
through Hong Kong we also saw a human
chain as well up until now though the
protests have been peaceful but the
concern of course among so many here is
how are police going to respond now that
they have the authority to to entertain
people for wearing face masks it is now
unlawful for people to attend these
protests with face masks on nevertheless
though the people that we've seen
defiant still wearing those masks
well after Friday night's violins the
leader of Hong Kong Carrie Lam made a
statement what was her message in a
pre-recorded televised statement Carrie
Lam fiercely condemned these protesters
once again she said that it was last
night was a dark day for Hong Kong she
said the city was half paralyzed by
these protests she called these
protesters riot it's a very sensitive
term here in Hong Kong because anyone
charged with rioting faces up to ten
years in prison she also called on
regular Hong Kong as to support the
government and distance themselves from
these protests the people that we've
spoken to though who are on the streets
marching today have said that she has
lost all credibility now that they are
not listening to what Carrie Lam is
saying they say any action by
authorities have come far too little far
too late to try and calm these protests
down well Charlotte you mentioned it
yourself these protesters appear
determined to continue wearing the face
masks continue going out onto the
streets have you seen any arrests or
Consequences up to now for the people
who are wearing those face masks and
protesting
it's been relatively peaceful so far we
are seeing images starting to circulate
on social media which have shown police
chasing down a man and a woman who were
pairing faith masks they were at the
scene of a protest that had finished a
couple of hours earlier but these
protesters chasing down this couple
we're seeing reports that the one woman
was left extremely shaken but what
people here are concerned about is that
is going to happen more and more
as the night as the days goes on but a
lot of concern here anger as well about
this face masked banner and other
emergency laws that could then come with
it
all right DW is Charlotte chosen pilled
reporting for us from Hong Kong thank
you very much